so sometimes you hear about
configuration spaces feature spaces
hyper spaces vector spaces whatever what
is a space well you will all have come
across them before as like scatter plots
or just graphs in general are a
representation of a space if you have a
two-dimensional space that just means
that you have two axes on your graph
you've made a plate right a flat surface
it's two-dimensional here's one
dimension here's the other dimension
right the thing we've got some animals
and we want to think about those animals
in a more rigorous way than just just
talking about them we want to do some
maths about the properties of these
animals like we're interested in the
color of them and their weight or
something like that their size so so
let's say with some random species of
animal where the females tend to be red
and large and the males tend to be blue
and small for example so you've got two
axes here and you can say this one here
is size and this is color on a scale of
red to blue right so so you've got like
a zero is red this is just a random
example and a hundred is blue and then
so you know 50 is like purple and then
if you've got a group of these animals
you can then plot them so suppose you've
got some over here each one of these
crosses represents a single specific
animal and each of these circles is also
an animal in this case this is a female
and if I remember correctly and you can
look at this and if you want a machine
to do something intelligent you want a
machine to understand this there are
things that you can see you can see
firstly that there's these sort of
clusters there are clustering algorithms
that will automatically identify and
observe drawing a circle around this and
saying that's one cluster and a circle
around this
that's another cluster when Amazon is
trying to tell you what kind of things
it thinks that you want to buy it may
make a space of all of its users with
each person being a point in that space
and the dimensions being what things
they bought then you'll find that the
difference between you and another
person you can place a number on it how
similar are we you know have I bought
the same kind of things that you've
bought there are algorithms that do that
or algorithms where they can sort of
look at this space and sort of draw a
line through it and say okay well it
seems like so if anything on this side
seems to be male and anything on this
side seems to be female even though
there's overlap even though this is
fuzzy you can make an educated guess
based on these properties and you can do
other things like take this and say okay
of this cluster where's the middle of it
where's the densest area what does a
typical female size look like what does
a typical female color look like what is
a typical male color size so if you've
got your average one here and you've got
your average one here then you can draw
a line between them for example in this
space and then say okay then you can map
everything onto this line and then you
get a continuum between male and female
there's no white shows male and females
getting into like politics which is not
wrong trying to go with this but just as
an example so the point is various
things like you can say how a female is
this specific one and then you can
actually measure it right before you had
to just kind of guess but now you can
say well it's you take the average you
take the distance to the average you
just measure what this distance is and
that gives you an actual number that you
can use you're taking stuff that would
normally require a human intelligence
how typical is this or how how male is
this or whatever and you are turning it
into numbers you're turning it into mass
so that a computer can understand it so
here this is an example of a two
dimensional space right but if we chose
to model a third thing about the animals
I don't know the speed that they run or
something we could have a third axis
right you could you could have this one
coming off here being speed we end up
with a three dimensional graph and now
it's very difficult because I'm I have
two dimensional paper and I'm trying to
express the three dimensional ID on it
but basically so these end up being all
spread out each of these dots is now
somewhere along this speed axis as well
they form a 3d sort of cloud so this
line would become a surface a plate here
you have a two dimensional space to
divide it in half you need a one
dimensional object which is a line here
we have a three dimensional space that
have divided it up we need a two
dimensional object the dividing line is
always one less number of dimensions
than the space when measuring three
things about these animals we could
measure any number of things right we
could measure 150 things and that's fine
the maths works exactly the same in 150
dimensions you can't draw it on a piece
of paper you can't think about it in
your head but the maths is the same and
oh yeah we should talk about feature
vectors totally straightforward so when
we have a two-dimensional space you take
a particular creature there we are
this red rabbit and we measure how much
it weighs we're doing size by weight
let's say and we say that it weighs you
know a gram and we say what color is it
well it's red it's really very red so
it's about zero and this this is now a
feature vector it's a feature vector of
length two because it's a two
dimensional space so each data point is
represented by a feature vector which is
a point in the feature space so there's
some fun stuff that's been done with for
example faces right human faces to look
at a human face and say is that a male
face or a female face that's the kind of
thing that you would think that you
really needed a human to do how would
you even go about telling a computer how
to do that right this is the kind of
challenge that these kinds of algorithms
can tackle so it works out to be exactly
the same you measure a load of things
about the fate you know the distance
between the eyes and the length of the
nose and the width of the mat you
measure everything you can measure about
the face and then you plot them all in a
very high dimensional space
you tell it certain things which one
smell on the terms of female you find
the average male in the average female
and that's interesting as well because
then you can take this data you can take
this point in space right each point in
space represents a possible face
everywhere in the space
is a face it's a face space if you will
right yeah yeah it was a failed social
network but so it's a feat it's a
feature space right our faces and then
these certain points represent specific
faces that you've actually loaded in and
said to this as a man's face this is the
woman's face one of them so then you can
find the typical male face but then you
can do the same thing where you plot a
line from the typical males with a
difficult female this line is is
indefinitely long which means you can
take for example a face and you can make
a face which is more male than any
actual human person's face right or more
female in the mathematics of this
emerges completely naturally or just
following this line along you end up
with these grotesque things but a
certain percentage away past the end
what you end up with is kind of cartoon
caricatures so the male's end up with
these like vast you know big brows and
big bulky jaws and the women have like
enormous eyes if they end up looking
like anime characters or whatever before
you have this kind of concept how do you
even approach the concept of how do you
draw a caricature of a human being with
a computer but now we can do it right
because we have this concept of doing
basically geometry in a feature space
generally when you when you throw
real-world data into one of these spaces
that it will be clustered because the
real world does tend to be clustered
right it's just kind of the way that
things tend to work out so people who
are like me will be next to me in Amazon
I'll be I'll be I'll be part of a
cluster of people about my age my gender
my you know level of education and
wealth and everything else people who
tend to buy similar things and so then
if somebody who's very close to me in
that cluster buy something else then
they can kind of infer that I might be
likely to buy that thing as well that's
something that that Amazon does
something that you know Netflix does
with their films all of these kind of
all of these kind of predictive things
where you just throw the data in and the
maths doesn't really know what it's
dealing with it doesn't know that I'm a
that I'm a person not an animal or that
what I'm measuring here is you know
propensity for buying computer games
instead of mass the matter is broadly
the same and so you can make you can
make computers tackle all sorts of
problems which which previously they
couldn't if you take a celebrity and you
draw a line between average and the
celebrity and then continue that line
somewhere out along that line is a
cartoon caricature of that celebrity
right because you've taken the ways in
which their face is different from the
typical average face and extended it and
exaggerated them and this is exactly
what caricature artists do but now we
can do it with maths